parent
je
m
salut à tous bienvenue à mercredi à
saint joseph pour vous parler d'une
discipline olympique un sport collectif
plein d'histoires à la réunion dix sept
clubs 5514 licenciés et pour nous en
parler sylvain waro cette discipline
c'est quoi sylvain et basket ball c'est
parti
g
sylvain est l'illustration du travail de
fond entrepris par ce groupe de
basketteurs de saint joseph de 130
licenciés 13 entraîneurs bénévoles ici
et là jeunesse est une force
on a commencé tout petit en 1998 avec va
licencier de coach
bénévoles et maintenant 2013 ça fait
quinze ans d'existence et on est de 130
licenciés avec treize bénévoles c'est
géré comme une entreprise mais on essaye
de garder par dessus tout le côté
familial proche
le noyau dur c'est les mêmes qui étaient
là et qu'ils étaient là dès le début
c'est rare les présidents 22 ans et
ouais c'est vrai mais moi envie
d'essayer de me dire que je vis ma
passion autrement ce soit dans notre
oeil parce que je fais je jauge arbitré
le musée que le devenir président ça
serait peut-être devoir encore une fois
différemment
on va enchaîner sur le jeu à trois
contre trois vous savez que le jeu à 3-3
dans la catégorie benjamin et le jeu de
passes et va c'est la base des
fondamentaux collectifs la plus
importante on sort de la catégorie
benjamins il faut maîtriser le jeu de
passe et va donc trois contes 3 et 6 3
contre 3 ici ceux qui jouent pas ils
arbitrent
voilà le cachet de ce club que ce soit
les sections sportives collèges ou
lycées où le simple pratique en tout le
monde les initier aux différentes
composantes de ce sport
fait partie de cette école de la vie à
15 ans en plus d'être l'une des
meilleures cadettes de lille mais les
arbitres fédérale
sabine on a envie de savoir ce que tu as
fait d'être de l'autre côté du
terrain en fait à tous ceux qui crient
qu'on fait en musique à tous ceux qui
sont qui comprennent par une décision
qui survie de leur dire on est face aux
joueurs qu'on prend une décision on est
face aux joueurs on va pas c'est vrai
qu'on a un collègue c'est en binôme
c'est une décision personnelle donc
c'est assez dur oui enfin oui pour
l'instant orient
je ne